with over 300 sessions at next 2023 it's
understandable that you couldn't get to
them all so if you didn't see five
practical considerations for adopting AI
then stay tuned because here's the
[Music]
rewind AI has the potential to transform
all Industries and is being adopted at
an unprecedented rate and one of the
most common question questions we get is
what is actually going to create value
for my business and what should I
consider in formulating my AI roadmap so
let's start with business value created
by AI typically companies look to
improve an existing workflow or solve a
new problem that couldn't be solved
before and AI can help deliver new
insights from data increase employee
productivity and speed up time to
Innovation and it all starts with use
case priority ization where we recommend
looking at three things business impact
the bottom line increasing revenue or
decreasing costs including employee
productivity ease of implementation
which depends on data availability and
difficulty of methodology used impacting
time to
Market and lastly the capabilities built
where are some repeatable patterns
across the business where have you built
training or monitoring capabilities that
could be
reused bring together business and
Technical stakeholders to define the use
cases and success however in such a
quickly moving field it's critical to
experiment and iterate with traditional
AI that took a lot of time data experts
and stages but fortunately with
generative AI that life cycle is
dramatically shortened so while it may
still feel a bit intimidating or
open-ended gen enables rapid and
efficient experimentation even if you're
not using an out-of-the-box solution or
if you're only supplementing a workflow
with AI but of course your key output to
all this experimentation is data and
what it tells you about your actual
improvements and for that we suggest
focusing on three
areas
accuracy consider grounding in the truth
of what your goals are it's going to be
different for Creative Marketing than it
would be for obtaining facts or
summaries impact does this solution
solve a problem add revenue or lower
costs and efficiency you want to make
sure that this makes sense for your
business to get the best results and
performance you also need to evaluate at
several steps from finding to tuning and
validating your model output to ongoing
measurement and evaluation especially
for emerging gen products while
researchers continue to improve model
evaluation first principles like
evaluating against your own defined
goals and budget are reasonable targets
like having a data set that's sufficient
for what you want to measure defining
quality metrics that are important for
you and keeping your decision space
small what are you willing to adjust of
course Enterprise Readiness is essential
for adopting AI unfortunately Enterprise
Readiness is foundational to all of our
AI
products and while the customer is
responsible for aspects of maintaining
their environments building on Google
Cloud means that we share that security
responsibility with you and we take that
shared responsibility one step further
to operate in a shared fate model with
our customers with Google Cloud secure
AI framework or
safe safe is a conceptual framework for
securing AI systems inspired by security
best
practices this ensures that when AI
models are implemented they're secure by
default and this means that you can
build secure private AI applications
without expending massive
resources but as your number of use
cases increases you'll need to automate
this framework to scale which is where
mlops comes in mlops is a set of
standardized processes and capabilities
for building deploying and
operationalizing ml systems rapidly and
reliably involving orchestrating and
automating the execution of continuous
training pipelines model deployment and
prediction serving data set and feature
management and Model Management and
governance and with geni organiz Iz
ation need to evolve their mlops
capabilities to address new challenges
with model adaptation like prompt
engineering and tuning techniques model
optimization for efficient deployment
and serving and additional guard rails
like safety scores filters DLP and even
human
feedback if you'd like to see the full
talk check out the link in the
description and don't forget to
subscribe to our YouTube channel for
more great next re rewi content thanks
for
watching